I'm Eric Schmidt, Executive Chairman of Google.
The biggest change for consumers is going to be that everyone's gonna have a smartphone.
And the fact that so many people are connected to what is essentially a supercomputer...
...means a whole new generation of applications around entertainment,...
...education, social life, those kinds of things.
The trend has been that mobile was winning; it's now won.
There are more tablets and phones being sold than personal computers,...
...people are moving to this new architecture very fast.
The biggest disruptor that we're sure about...
...is the arrival of big data and machine intelligence everywhere.
So the ability to find people, to talk specifically to them,...
...to judge them, to rank what they're doing,...
...to decide what to do with your products, changes every business globally.
The biggest disruption that we don't really know what's gonna happen...
...is probably in the genetics area.
The ability to have personal genetic records...
...and ability to start gathering all of the gene sequencing into places...
...will yield discoveries in cancer treatment and diagnostics over the next year...
...that are unfathomably important.